I got Steve's moving in right now so
you're saying Steve needs to live here
mm-hmm but I think he likes to live like
a communist no no no Steve's a survivor
he's like a roach
you could pick him up and put him
anywhere he'll set up base camp that's
just how he is leaves ready for the
zombie apocalypse okay a lot like my dad
my dad had us we lived in San Diego and
he had a store in Sacramento mm-hmm
right so he would drive every other week
to Sacramento and just stay a week what
kind of a store we own clothing stores
back in the 80s really janna clothes
it's fashion for women it was called
fashion gal did you have to work at the
store I did sometimes yeah oh my god
really my dad and my uncle's own 75 at
one point so what happened to all that
family money bankrupt oh but so my
brother and I one day go we go during
the summer we go dad we're gonna drive
up there with you because he's been for
years he was driving up there every
other week turned out it wasn't swap
meet I'm not kidding you right now dude
we went to this apartment where he lived
right no furniture not anything a little
like Korean mat no blanket right and a
little like one of those plug-in stoves
that's all that was in there that's how
he was little he had electricity on yeah
he had electricity on it like it was
just like a man would say in retrospect
that's what my brother is my brother
yeah my mom is the fancy one that's
where I take like she goes we make the
gazebo this summer so she made a gazebo
like she hired somebody else we got a
koi fish farm like she loves [ __ ] like
that that's why your dad needed a place
that it was just like you know your mom
free you know just like yeah yeah my dad
doesn't he didn't he doesn't watch TV
he's not he's never seen a TV show has
he seen you on TV yeah he's been on TV
oh oh yeah he was on MADtv a bunch of
time yeah he was getting residual checks
she had a son up for half
the Union sag your dad say yeah he was
that's how much we had him on but my dad
doesn't like music Wow
he didn't aim a Beatles song I don't
know I mean who who's Bob Dylan I don't
know he doesn't know anything you say
who's Tom Hank I don't know he doesn't
he doesn't know what a movie is he
probably didn't know what he was doing
so what I'm saying is is that what the
[ __ ] was he doing every night by himself
in a mat in an apartment with no
furniture no he was a [ __ ] jacking
off oh you think so hmm but it's so sad
to think about that
no he means I totally get it he had
these crazy kids there but back then
sure you guys were insane when you were
young yeah his wife was spending all his
money yeah you're right maybe that was
it he just needed to go I find it like a
like a man cave you know he also could
have had things that we don't know not
even aware of probably has another
family oh my god what would you do if
you found out her brothers brothers and
sisters all Koreans look the same anyway
so this could be possible are you
getting that on camera yeah he's got a
he's got racism on oh it's loud and damn
we don't you know that's the only people
can hear your ass before the cameras
start rolling really really my friend
let me say something right now with
stereo tires what you know that
stereotype Asian people look alike
yeah do we yes but do you sure no like
so what I'm saying all right all right
dude so have you been to the airport
walk by an Asian guy is that Bobby you
thought that one time I was oh oh really
it was like a little grandma same body
shape yeah you know all about saying
there's a similarity there is similarly
that's why you can go but first of all
could you pick a Korean out of a bunch
of people
what do you mean like if you saw like a
group of people you could go oh that
person's Korean yeah yeah you know why
why because there's distinct looking
things that are distinctly Korean that's
why you can go oh that guy's Korean yeah
but I could also go that's Sally the
Korean sometimes no all the time [ __ ]
not what they're all just the same at an
audition
still like I've never looked at Steven
Yeun and what Steve my brother you know
or I never looked at Daniel Dae Kim ago
is that song Kang mmm sometimes yeah but
definitely you don't look any like any
anybody ever that's very first I'm just
mixed he's half black
you know cam you know sometimes you need
to mail things and shameless right now
shameless shameless no but seriously